First of all, where does 5 fall on our distribution? Here, in between 3.4 and
8.2. How many standard deviations below the mean is that? Looks like about 1.5
or somewhere in between 1 and 2. So that's important. To keep in mind when we
use the z table. So what we need to do first is figure out exactly how many
standard deviations 5 is from 13. How far is 5 from 13? It's 8 away. And how
many standard deviations of 4.8 fit into 8? This is negative 1.67 if we round to
the nearest hundredths place. And remember, it's negative because 5 is less than
the mean. So now we can bring up our z table. So here's the z table. And I
shared it with you in the link at the bottom. So we have negative 1.6 here. And
for negative 1.67, we find where this row and this column, intersect. And that's
here at 0.0475. So if we look at our distrubution, then the proprotion less than
5 is 0.0475. That means that a little less than 5% of students have gotten less
than 5 points per post on average.